devez-vous continuer de payer les frais
de scolarité du collège privé si votre
enfant ne va plus à l'école
on a posé la question à la fédération
des établissements d'enseignement privés
alors vous ne serez pas surpris si je
vous dis qu ils nous ont répondu oui
mais je vous explique leur raisonnement
et vous pourrez comprendre leur position
de leur point de vue le service d'un
collège privé ayant un parent c'est
d'amener leurs enfants du point a au
point b en termes d'acquisition de
connaissances et de compétences
or malgré les difficultés liées au
confinement les professeurs travaillent
à l'heure actuelle pour couvrir le
programme scolaire
tout le monde est d'accord avec le fait
que cette année le chemin du point a au
point b est plus court que lors d'une
année normale ça c'est certain
vous l'avez remarqué les professeurs des
collèges privés donne du contenu font le
suivi sur les travaux qui sont données
vont évaluer le cheminement et porter un
jugement sur le cheminement des élèves à
la fin de l'année scolaire bref ils vont
voir à ce que des enfants soient prêts
pour le prochain niveau en septembre et
pour ceux bien sûr ils y reçoivent leur
salaire et le salaire des professeurs
c'est la principale dépense d'une école
alors je sais pas si ce raisonnement
vous a convaincu mais sachez que la
fédération des établissements
d'enseignement privés garde quand même
la porte ouverte à une diminution de la
facture une diminution des frais de
scolarité liées à l'enseignement
lorsqu'elle sera capable de faire
l'évaluation de son année scolaire parce
que c'est une drôle d'année scolaire
ceci étant dit il reste que les collèges
vont devoir diminuer la facture générale
parce que plusieurs services n'ont pas
été fournies je pense ici aux transports
scolaires aux sorties culturelles au
conférencier qui sont parfois invités
dans les collèges aux activités
parascolaires aux activités sportives
les collèges devront tenir compte de ça
pour offrir un crédit pour l'année
suivante ou un remboursement aux parents
parce que un service non rendu n'a pas à
être facturés alors conclusion si vous
avez des difficultés financières en
raison de la crise
contactez votre collège privé parce que
certains d'entre eux offrent le rapport
de paiement d'autres parfois même des
bourses
ça vaut la peine de porter
l'arrageois